[Music]
move out of the way
look to the right right tornado on the
ground right now moving over i-35 and
45.
35 meets 45 toll this is live from round
rock on our whittlesea camera we have a
confirmed tornado on the ground
take down the banner please
moving across i-35 this is evening rush
hour traffic there are people on those
flyovers there are people on the
interstate below you can see a lot of
brake lights as they see what we're
seeing
let's not move off this camera there's
flying debris
on the 45 flyover
in round rock
take me a little bit right this is why
we need to take these tornado warnings
seriously
it's on the ground
hey you got me hey we got a tornado on
the ground guys tornado on the ground
right there in front of us
i'm thankful to report that we have no
injuries of students or staff
and i'm not aware of any parents that
were on any of our campuses that
sustained any injuries so
we feel very blessed
to to have that news it just brought
tears to my eyes it's hard to see that
you know i've lived here for 15 years i
love this place
and so it was hard and
they i keep hearing i haven't seen that
i don't have a roof on my own house so
but you know my kids are safe my
husband's safe and you know all the
students at jisd are safe so that's
what's important
[Music]